so here's the thing this is actually you
know you do all these things you produce
you direct you act you write but I don't
think we've had this before where
someone is come on the show and you
invented a board game like not just
invented it got me yeah yes that's true
do I have it what happened yes yes well
I was yeah when I was getting married
yep
that's it unveiled it's a bachelorette
party game it's a you know it's a party
in a box guys yeah it is an actual board
look there's it
there's our board no and I think the
pieces are little shoes right check
little shoes so I I you know you know
when you're in that time of your life
when every one you know is getting
married I was in that time I was
probably you know going to 15 weddings
or something and I I'm pretty good at
throwing a bachelorette party so I was
throwing bachelorette parties all the
time and we would do like a scavenger
hunt or you know all kinds of things and
and one day I don't know it I we met a
guy who made erotic games and he
basically thought he could sell a
bachelorette party game to would that
had a little some naughty erotic
elements to it which is what a
bachelorette or hen party I think you
guys call them right yeah head party
yeah so yeah it was like a way to
organize a bachelorette evening around
the game night so it was like early game
night stuff yeah those are the cars yeah
I mean yeah you can read some of that
you found this game first of all so some
of these cards so you have like a say
card which is something that you have to
that you say out loud so oh my god I
okay
why not hang on okay okay you know I'll
ask all right Jennifer
this says this is the full question okay
and here's the thing you can it says you
can play or pass so you don't have to
answer this I'm gonna pass this if you
want to okay the question is do you spit
or swallow do you return to start do you
like to play or pass
[Applause]
you can be talking about wine or
something oh yeah yeah I would never
spit out wine and then there's a way
okay so away cards these are this but
this is the part of the evening where
you leave the house because you can't
have a decent bachelor party Oh at home
you have like leave the house you got a
you know go you know see the Magic Mike
show or something and meet some meet
some dudes right so an away card might
involve for instance all right you ready
this is gonna be this will be for
eucharist okay so if you pick this card
you you need to go find this and and do
it this is the away card okay read
outloud it says kiss or rub a bald there
you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
apparently 25 years on I'm gonna start
selling games finally yeah what a fun
game do do a store full of these
[Music]
you